all right so you guys know I love the
alien stories I love conspiracy stories
I love sci-fi movies and the riot guys
brought me Jeremy Korbel from
extraordinary beliefs calm and they said
this is the guy that you have to talk to
about all this stuff because I'm
babbling on about this stuff constantly
and they said he's gonna come in and
clean up some of this stuff so first off
can you tell me a little bit about the
series you're doing your website things
like that and then right then I want to
get into some meat about what's really
going on here on earth yeah yeah that's
a good question
so my series is called extraordinary
beliefs and it's at extraordinary
beliefs calm extraordinary beliefs is
essentially a genesis of data and
information and interviews that have
gone on for the last six years I have
kind of delved into some of the biggest
questions that we have you know the
technologies that are available right
now the whole idea of the UFO phenomenon
what actually is going on from a
governmental side as well as from the
individual experience or side so
extraordinary beliefs calm is
essentially an investigative film series
into the extraordinary beliefs of
credible individuals right so what are
some extraordinary beliefs besides say
believing in UFOs what are the
extraordinary beliefs that that you
believe in me personally that you
believe in or that you're trying to
prove either are true or not true I know
okay so they're not you're not really
trying to prove no they know that you're
trying to present that's the idea I'm
taking you know people who are of high
credibility who have belief systems that
are outside that of the norm and I am
listening to what they have to say
documented recording and I am allowing
them to testify and amplifying their
story so it's not me trying to prove a
belief although I do have my own
understanding of the universe and I the
weight of the evidence has become heavy
for certain things such as visitation
from other intelligences but I'm not
trying to prove anything because you you
have to weaponize your own curiosity you
you need to be interested right you know
I'm interested
can I get you interested right so I like
that jumping-off point because you're
not
saying that this is specifically true
you're looking for sort of empirical
evidence to prove that something either
is or isn't true so let's start by
talking about aliens as I said it's my
favorite topics jump right let's jump
right into aliens we're not gonna mess
around okay right into aliens yeah yeah
okay so we see footage of things all the
time we see footage of UFOs and you know
something in the distance and a die
walking in a forest and all these things
what for you would count as real
evidence if could someone hand you
something that was videotaped or a shot
digitally or something and would that be
enough is there anything that would be
enough to be to qualify as real evidence
you know it's the first question that I
asked a number of people when I started
this journey is you know can you put
something in my hand I very quickly
decided to turn the cameras kind of you
know away from the sky and towards the
individuals who have experienced things
because you learn a lot more so the
evidence for me is is best described or
the most compelling evidence is the
testimony from individuals who are
involved at various levels from
governmental levels to personal
experience levels who have nothing to
gain and everything to lose by telling
me an extraordinary story that is some
of the best evidence rather than if I
personally have an experience and I see
something earth-shattering like did you
see if they're gonna be like at a guy
with the website right but that's cool I
wish I did see some of these like that
these people are seeing and and I
haven't I've seen some extraordinary
things that I can't they don't compute I
don't know how to you know where to they
go in a grey basket but I don't
definitively know as you said the word
aliens that these are so what is alien
alien is anything we don't understand
yet this may be a natural phenomenon and
what we're experiencing are kind of
repercussions of that we don't exactly
know right so that's sort of like when
they say an unidentified flying object
that doesn't mean it's from another
world it just means it's unidentified
calls them you AP's unidentified aerial
phenomena and that's two separate even
more from the reality that there are
discs there are hard physical craft that
are traveling in our airspace with
impunity and this is something that's
been going on since the beginning of
recorded human history but the military
got really interested in this all
in the early 40s so that is true and
that is a fact we have radar reports air
radar ground radar air visual ground
visual we have trained observers people
who have interacted with these discs I
even you know interviewed a number of
people who are involved in
back-engineering programs but the point
is is that that the top of it is that
what this is all about right is it about
discs in the sky I think it's about a
lot more than that so all right so back
to the original question then if so
you're saying that the the biggest
evidence for you would be someone that
really told you that they experienced it
and they have a lot to lose and nothing
to gain but as someone that believes in
science that's sort of a hard way to
quantify this right always right I mean
the best evidence would be to experience
something personally but I do not have
the ability to like you know bring this
into my backyard so can you give me an
example of like someone that you talk to
that told you of an experience that was
so profound that you thought all right
yeah well absolutely there so remember
there's there's people of high
credibility but did they have the access
and so that's the difference someone in
a position who would be able to know
these things that's very different right
so we held my friends and I held along
from 2013 the Citizen hearing on
disclosure and this was where we had a
panel of 40 witnesses including the
Defense Minister of Canada astronauts
tonight video okay so that was my friend
Ruben Langdon's and my company that was
already bent and we had people testify
over a week at the National Press Club
about their involvement in the cover-up
or their direct experiences with these
unknown objects of unknown origin so for
me that was very compelling to sit for a
week and to listen to the testimony of
again intelligence officials military
for astronauts pilots had a
second-in-command to the FAA john
callahan hearing these people talk about
their experiences is compelling the
weight becomes heavy yeah we are there
is a there is a phenomenon we seem to be
in a place where we are being visited by
other intelligences now where they're
from
you know another planet another
dimension I have no idea I just know
they don't man you got to give me one
planet or dimension give me something
you know I would be really sad if it was
they were coming from other solar
systems
because that would be a much smaller
understanding then I think is really the
truth I I truly believe that the
phenomenon is bigger than that I don't
think these are just craft or Scouts or
probes with occupants or not coming from
other solar systems it doesn't make
sense there's a much bigger picture when
you really look into it yeah all right
well we're gonna do a bunch more with
Jeremy but as I think this was a good
jumping-off point so what do you think
are you a believer what would it take to
get you to believe do you have to see it
with your own eyes or with someone
else's evidence work for you let us know
in the comments right down below all
right so if aliens were actually here
which I certainly think is a possibility
I think there is potential that a higher
intelligence is visiting maybe watching
something I don't know but I think it is
certainly a possibility
wouldn't they be advanced enough to
never even give us a hint that they
exist so it doesn't that make this whole
conversation kind of tough because if
they were so advanced then they wouldn't
need us to know right and then at the
same level maybe we found something out
about them that they weren't prepared
for etcetera etcetera you make actually
a really good point you know we can map
the entire surface of the moon with two
probes that we sent up and anybody if
they were living on the moon we would
never know the difference so why are
these close contacts occurring
throughout human history you know why do
you even need this as soon as you really
ask the big question there which is that
yes an advanced civilization that was
here to monitor or map simply the earth
itself or our evolution would never ever
need to be recognized by us I agree with
you yeah so because the point being that
they would be so advanced that it they
wouldn't just come here with a giant
ship and be watching it we'd all be
looking at assumptions I mean we don't
know what an advanced you know specie
would would want right right so there
seems to be something more than that
going on that there certainly are you
know things going through our airspace
with impunity but additionally to that
from the military perspective of
national security there's the human
experience these stories are profound
there and they equate across the board
their similarities between all of them
there is something more going on with
these individuals who are
and sing these entities yeah give me
gonna be like what's the most concrete
story that you've heard that sort of
transcended between a lot of different
people from all over the place like give
me what's like one really is I was just
I was just in Arizona where they had a
very famous event called the Phoenix
lights and the Phoenix lights was this
huge craft that hovered and and slowly
traversed the airspace of Phoenix
Arizona thousands and thousands of
people saw it silent huge I mean you
can't even understand the size of a
couple football fields of a craft right
now governor Fife Symington I believe
his name is he at the time denied it he
made a joke of it he held the press
conference had a little alien guy come
in with a mask and then about ten years
later he went on a documentary and said
I did that for public panic I saw it too
and it was not of this earth so that's
why I just went on a Fox News show and
talked about it because they're really
interested so that is an event the
Phoenix lights were thousands and
thousands of people saw the same thing
yeah and it was all covered up so is
this one of these things where we
fundamentally and I think this is in a
weird way like very unique to America we
have like a severe distrust of the
government which sometimes I think is
healthy but it in another way hurts us
what do you think the government's angle
is they have earned our distrust yeah
especially on this issue you know we
know the FBI we know the CIA have been
studying this we know the Navy the army
the Air Force has been studying this we
have documents yet they throw the smoke
and mirrors nothing to see here move on
they have earned our distrust on this
topic now what what is what is the
agenda why you know the the greatest
thing that I've come to is that a
technological advantage means that you
are a superior nation if you in a way if
you have a technological advantage yeah
you get to say it louder at least you
get to say it louder and so for me
that's kind of the best argument that
why would a government cover this up
there's two reasons one is they want a
technological advantage and two is the
reality is stranger than you think yeah
and that's the weird one right so I tend
to think it would be the second one that
it would be something that would be so
crazy if another civilization was
watching us that they think all hell
would break loose if we found out
we're beyond that you know the every
religion on the planet has basically
come from the idea of people from the
heavens coming down and creating their
race I mean I I don't you know that so
do you think those things do you think
those things are connected because you
hear a lot about that that a lot of like
religious dogma is based in what people
said aliens came here and you know
aliens built the pyramids or you hear
that kind of thing like and that's where
religious dogma came from like actual
aliens visiting along yeah a lot of you
can see I watch a lot of ancient no are
you doing your you know and a lot of
people say that that we have been
influenced and that our culture has been
influenced humanity has even been
genetically altered or influenced by
visitors now it's certainly in the texts
like we know that for sure
beings that ascend and descend you know
from essentially ships you know this is
almost in every religion that in some
way there are star beings or beings from
from the heavens that come down now is
that true I have no idea I don't even
know if the written word is true but
there's certainly evidence to suggest
that we are not alone yeah never have
been our aliens watching us right now
are you watching us right now no in the
comments right down below all right so
what the hell is going on in area 51 I
want an answer right now got the
official line what's going on in area 51
is a place where we had great innovation
back in the day so the sr-71 was
developed at area 51 a lot of stealth
technologies were developed at area 51
in fact though area 51 has sub bases so
for example there is a base called s4
and this is south of groom lake by
Papoose Lake now this has been verified
to me in a numerous ways that I'm going
to be presenting in some of my films
okay I have a short film if you go to
alien propulsion comm it's about a man
named Bob Lazar Bob Lazar is the cosmic
whistleblower he was tasked by the
federal government to back engineer
saucers craft from not from here right
so area 51 is a place where great
technology was developed but the actual
projects that are you know offworld
allegedly we're from or taking care of
in other places such as s4 by Papoose
Lake yeah so what would you say to the
people that will say well you
there was something really going on in
area 51 and if they were hiding
something and if aliens had really
visited but there would be no way to
keep the secret yeah that's a lack of
imagination
anybody who spent time in the military
will tell you not only do we have
secrets but we keep them it is not hard
to keep a secret yeah and so that's a
real lack of imagination you know we
have secrets we keep secrets and this is
the biggest one a very important one
because of the technologies right so
speaking the technologies every time we
do an alien story or anything about the
future I'm a firm believer that if the
aliens get here first they ultimately
will destroy us and if we were to get to
another planet we would destroy them
because we see what we do to humans here
every time anyone explores anywhere what
do you do you end up killing them and
taking all their resources that is what
avatar is all about a million other
sci-fi movies which I want to get to in
a second but does that theory make sense
you not know this no no hopefully
there'd be a courtship period we're all
in luck well I didn't have a little of
that like we'd be very wowed by them but
ultimately because if they left their
planet it stands to reason that they
were explored because they needed
something like we're gonna destroy Earth
on our own right there you have to go
that may be true but you have to look at
it a few different ways you know one is
is that we may be an asset to them and
that's the thing your life itself is
precious so that you know life itself
may be an asset we don't really know
what the end game is and I'd also have
to say that it is the evidence has shown
that in my personal opinion that there
has been contact and it's been going on
for a long time we're still here yeah so
give me again give me the example of
contact that way that someone can watch
this and be like all right yeah well so
you know you have kind of these cursor
Airy things so in 1952 the flyover over
Washington DC and this was in every
paper this was a flap of objects that
were able to outrun even our best
fighter planes at the time this is a
where our airspace was kind of taken
over now contact itself that seems to
occur on an individual basis it's really
you know no one's come down and said
here's the mothership you know it's not
in the timeframe that we're talking
about modern humanity
right so why does everyone always say
well it's always backwards Hicks in the
middle of Kentucky let's absolutely
untrue yeah but that is you always hear
that right because that is propaganda
that's been put forward by every new
source of grass lawn is they love to
play the x-files in the background and
they love to like make fun of it it's a
laugh factor because you are silly
enough to believe that you are the most
intelligent species in the universe
right I mean it's ridiculous okay so but
that's why that's why you get that laugh
actor it's not Hicks in the backwoods
although there is a there are waves of
these craft that seem to occur in non
populated or less populated areas right
but that you know again watch the
Citizen hearing on disclosure you have
the most credible sources you could
possibly find who are testifying these
are not Hicks in the back although the
Hicks they probably got it right - I
mean well that's the other thing you'd
only seems to me that couldn't you argue
that if they were just targeting Hicks
whatever I don't know lead in that word
but if they were just targeting these
people that are on trust dis radical
yeah uncredible people that in a weird
way that would actually make sense
because they could learn about humans
from someone that the humans then
wouldn't trust as opposed to going to
somebody that we all trusted they went
to Oprah but they didn't want us to know
about it then that would be a would be
amazed to you know the believers are
like you know you know President Carter
who is on just on Jimmy Kimmel was both
Obama and President Clinton President
Clinton openly talked about how he
tasked his first task and getting into
office was sending somebody to find out
one of two things or two things yeah who
killed Kennedy oddly enough I guess as a
president you want to know and then you
know do we have aliens at area 51 he was
unable to get access because what people
don't understand is the president might
have the clearance but does not have the
need to know more the reverse so that's
like the plausible deniability line from
Independence Day well the last when the
president walked in with Bob lemon walks
in right yeah yeah why did I know about
this guy's like well plausible
deniability right that's it that's a
great scene but the last president that
really had the you know military
background to be tuned in was Eisenhower
after that everything changed men are
the aliens coming to destroy us or will
we destroy them first let us know in the
comments right down below alright so I
can't talk about aliens and
strange beliefs and skeptics and all
that stuff without talking about some
movies because I think my whole my whole
ethos on this was built basically by
science-fiction movies and I've seen
pretty much everyone that people talk
about as being things that define them
what's it for me well for me my defining
sci-fi movie was contact yeah which was
written by Carl Sagan it was his only
non-fiction book no his only fiction
books are nonfiction fiction nonfiction
I'm not sure it was only it was his only
fiction book he of course was a great
scientist and he was really neil
degrasse tyson before he was that movie
i actually went to see i had eaten pot
brownies and i was going to see boogie
nights and it was sold out and i ended
up in contact oh you've no idea what a
man i mean it literally blew my mind it
changed everything that i think and I
think contact is sort of exactly what
you're talking about with a lot of this
stuff this sort of subtle knowing of
contact but not they're not going to
necessarily like the prime directive you
know with Star Trek which I'm not a big
fan of my friend is a Eugene Roddenberry
so he you know the idea of
non-interference you know this is this
is very possible now interestingly
enough about contact one of the
characters in contact was the bald guy
that was up in orbit because he had
cancer yeah that guy was modeled after a
really amazing business tycoon named
Robert Bigelow you might know his name
because Bigelow right now currently has
two personal orbiting space habitats he
got the contract to put the inflatables
onto the ISS and what colonize or mine
the moon right this is Robert Bigelow so
this movie you're talking about was not
far from reality yeah in the sense that
they're dealing with real people with
real ideas so just look at that equation
% well that's that's why I love contact
because it was written by Carl Sagan
he's a master at explaining science and
this was his way of sort of like with a
palatable so interstellar so let's talk
about that for a little bit cuz that's
enough I loved it because it felt like
this stuff is kind of real it's close
yeah we're exploring the universe man
we're talking literally about mining the
moon and colonizing Mars nobody laughs
at that anymore I mean this is a specie
leaving moving offworld and
starting to touch and engage the outside
environment if not live there I mean it
is absolutely fascinating this is real
life real world is happening now right
so doesn't some of this go to what we
were talking about in the previous
segment which is sort of the avatar idea
now we're gonna wreck this planet and
then we're gonna have to go somewhere
else and then that's where the really
interesting stuff happens because then
we are potentially the invaders of
another planet and another species I
don't want to be a pessimist I think
human beings are doing pretty darn well
we have our issues but you know I think
that we're also problem solvers so I am
an optimist in this sense I think true
exploration is going to come from from a
wealth of economy a wealth of curiosity
I don't think that if we're having so
many bad problems on earth that we're
gonna naturally just say let's go
somewhere else right that if we thrive
here we can explore there so we have to
keep it tighter in home right and in
order to do that so I think it's a it's
a reflection of a great society if you
can reach out to the stars
right so jumping back to interstellar
first yes because there was a lot there
how much of this do you think will be
related to time travel with that
continue it you can't really you cannot
separate them because the way that these
crafts allegedly you know travel or
traverse space time is by distorting
gravity so the classic example is a
gravity wave amplifier the idea that if
you can distort with high energy
space-time in front of you you are a
time traveler by being a space traveler
right so this is that was sort of an
interstellar like that's the part that
can make your brain explode it's one
thing to be like that we go to the
planets maybe some aliens but this other
piece of people aging differently and
all that stuff right just it's the basic
idea is that time is a fabric it can be
folded it can be bent so that's why when
they got near the black hole all of a
sudden time shifted for the different
you know sets of people where they were
because the gravity its gravity gravity
is what warps space or space-time simple
right so okay I've answered the question
of my favorite sci-fi movie oh gosh et
yeah I mean I mean like things right
there's there's uh a lien it's hidden
there's probably bad aliens there's
probably good aliens there's good people
there's bad people I mean you know I
just thought he was cute yeah all right
well I could literally talk to Jeremy
all day about this stuff and I
absolutely will have you back to further
the discussion because I just love this
stuff but tell everybody a little bit
more about where they can find you and
everything else that you're doing I'm
not hey right over there I'm not hiding
it's super easy go to extraordinary
beliefs calm and I like to say weaponize
your imagination or your curiosity
everything is on there a bunch of films
that I made again I'm a documentary
filmmaker primarily yeah everything that
you see there's like The Twilight Zone
except it's real Twilight Zone but real
alright and be on the lookout for the
story that we're doing at riot dot-org
with jeremy and it'll also be on the
youtube channel which we are annotating
to break